the bachelor and bachelorette franchise  is headed to paradise some of your  favorite contestants are traveling to  toll in Mexico for another shot at love  Michelle Money Chris Bukowski and one of  the favorites bachelorette Andi season  Markel Martin are all among the cast  there's definite arid ice but it has its  twists and turns each week new arrivals  will change everything bachelor in  paradise was was a totally different  ride in itself it was emotional roller  coaster also joining from marquel season  is Marcus and there are rumors that he  won over and is now engaged to Juan  Pablos former flame Lacey I can't say I  can't confirm or deny that you can see  how all the drama unfolds when the show  premieres August fourth  you